let's talk about 11 different causes of
leg pain okay
number one lactic acidosis now what the
heck is that well without getting
too
technical it's a condition where you
have
too much
acid going on in your legs okay lactic
acid
and that is coming from your diet you're
consuming too many carbs and sugar
and you're severely lacking vitamin b1
and so now what's happening is you're
getting a combination of acidity
and lack of oxygen hypoxia okay and your
legs are going to be very very restless
you're going to feel
very uncomfortable in the legs
especially at night
i had this condition
uh for quite some years i would
literally get up in the middle of the
night and have to pound my legs because
they were so full of energy
and i had to go running i was running in
the middle of the night to try to get
this energy out because they were
restless okay they would not let me
sleep little did i know that a pint of
ben and jerry's ice cream every night
for probably over a year
caused this condition not to mention the
other carbs i was consuming
the more carbohydrate and sugar that you
eat the more b1 that you need to
metabolize it okay and so that's the
underlying cause it's a b1 deficiency
causing this because the diet's too high
in carbohydrate
number two pinched nerve okay now of
course being a chiropractor i've dealt
with this a lot you can have sciatica
pain you can have some nerve root
pinched on one side that goes right down
the leg that's not necessarily sciatica
it's just a different nerve you have to
realize the sonic is a very big nerve
it's like the width of my thumb goes in
the back part of your leg all the way
down to the foot and if there's some
type of pinching whether it is arthritis
a bone out of place a disc that could be
one of the causes in which you'd want to
go to a competent chiropractor to get it
checked out i have some videos on
sciatica the the key with sciatica is
keeping the lower back curve in
so you need a little cushion when you
sit down and to keep that curve going
inward
because when you lose the curve you
start getting more compression and that
can pinch the nerves right there and of
course with arthritis if you're
consuming a lot of omega-6 fatty acids
the soy oil the corn oil the canola
those type of things as well as refined
carbs
you're going to be in a constant
inflamed state that's going to keep the
nerve pinched regardless of what type of
treatment that you you get
number three obstruction in your
arteries okay in the legs and so one
form of this obstruction or blockage is
called intermittent claudication
so intermittent means it comes and goes
okay so let's say you start exercising
and your legs start going numb or they
get cold or they get weak that could be
coming from this obstruction in your
arteries and it's called intermittent
clarication also the circulation in your
legs decreases to the point where you
lose the hair in your legs the skin on
your legs becomes shiny
but typically this is worse with
activity especially if you're going up a
hill okay your legs just don't have the
oxygen
to move so you're not going to be a very
fast runner all right number four low
vitamin d which is behind
growing pains now a lot of teenagers
experience growing pains right well it
has really nothing to do with their
growing okay it has to do with a vitamin
d deficiency if you give a little
vitamin d
boom completely goes away and they
usually get this at night okay in the
middle of the night for a few hours and
then it gets better worse and it it can
be like a cramping in their calves or it
can be in the quads
now vitamin d is uh really important in
preventing inflammation and pain in your
lower back
so if you're deficient you can have a
lot of lumbar problems in the lower back
as well as pelvic problems that can
affect your ability to walk it can even
if you're really deficient as a an
infant it can cause
distortion of the spine it can affect
the curve of the spine it can affect
scoliosis and this creates all sorts of
problems with movement and motions
because the muscles are connected to the
bones and so i think most people would
be very surprised how common this is
with leg pain not just low back pain but
leg pain so as a if you're confused
what's going on and you have leg pain
just start taking about 40 000 ius of
vitamin d and within probably a day
you're going to find that that leg pain
eases up tremendously number five
diabetes now why
would you have leg pain with diabetes
there's a condition called peripheral
neuropathy okay
so this is nerve damage caused because
of the vascular component the
capillaries
get damaged and they can't feed the
nerves okay in your feet it can be their
feet pain or leg pain and then it
spreads into the hands and arms it's
called peripherals because those are the
peripheral parts of your body okay now
what's interesting about this one is the
remedy for this is actually the same as
for number one
well actually it's also the same for
this one too obstruction in your artery
because if there's a
some type of
arterial sclerosis or clot or plaquing
that's usually too many carbs right so
too many carbs for sugar too much carb
or sugar too much carb or sugar
the remedy for this is vitamin b1 but
you would want to
give it in a
form that goes into the fat tissue like
the myelin sheath which is the outer
part of the nerve so you want to give a
person something called benfotamine okay
benfotamine
with this one you can give them just the
water soluble b1 i like nutritional
yeast
but ultimately the correction of this is
getting rid of the carbs but you can
actually make a person feel better by
just taking b1 and of course the same
remedy for this too all right number six
flat feet now if your foundation is
not supporting the whole body with the
correct arch well that can throw off
your knees it can throw off your hips it
can cause some serious serious leg pain
i'm speaking from experience i had flat
feet my whole life i used arch supports
didn't really work in fact it made
things worse um it wasn't until i got
rid of those and started working on
strengthening exercises and stretches
that i got relief with this and now i
wear these completely flat
sole shoes they're called the barefoot
shoes and they're great they force your
toes and your feet to actually
strengthen the muscles and it's the best
thing ever and of course this one is
tied in with a vitamin d deficiency
probably early on
okay number seven tight psoas and quads
i had this problem as well for many
years from riding a bike so you're doing
this one motion over and over and over
and you're strengthening your quads and
your psoas and then when you stand up
this is too tight and that's going to
throw up your back and that's going to
refer pain down to the legs so if we
take a look at this so far i had this
one this one
this one
almost had this one but not quite i was
a pre-diabetic this one right here and
this one so i'm talking from experience
but if we add number eight i've also had
old injuries and i'm talking to your
ankle okay
so let's say for example you sprained
your ankle or broke her ankle on one
side you're going to limp you're going
to put the pressure on the opposite side
so you're going to walk a little bit
differently you're going to adapt to
that and then
one two three years down the road
what's going to happen is you're going
to notice leg pain or ankle pain or knee
pain or back pain that's just because
your gait has been compensating
i have a really good
video on this i'm going to put it down
below and i also have a very good video
on this one too to how to reverse this
right here
but this can definitely
be a cause in fact you just want to ask
yourself
have you ever had any ankle injuries
foot injuries knee injuries okay have
you ever fallen your tailbone
those can come back to haunt you if you
don't know how to fix them and i'm going
to put some videos down on how to fix
them number nine deep vein thrombosis so
this is a little different than the
artery problem right here but you can
have an obstruction in the veins as well
coming from the same root cause because
there's an actual clot that's blocking
blood flow and that's definitely going
to cause leg pain all right 10
over training
so many people exercise
way too often not letting their legs
rest and recover and they end up having
soreness and then they exercise over
soreness and the exercise of soreness
and they're just not connecting the dots
if this person
gave themselves
like a week or maybe even two weeks of
rest
and then just noticed how much better
their muscles feel because they allowed
it to rest
they would really get it but they're
just so used to this you have to
exercise every day you know there's a
couple points about weak muscles and
nutrition
if you're low in vitamin e
your muscles will be
a bit weak okay
and you should even test that if you
ever feel kind of weak sometimes take
some vitamin e wait about an hour and
see how much stronger you feel
okay when you walk and exercise
low sodium
or low salt
especially when you're doing fasting can
make your muscles weak it's another
cause
now low omega-3 will increase the time
of soreness
so this person that does training should
increase their omega-3 to decrease
soreness and increase
recovery all right number 11 stenosis
what is that well you have the spinal
column okay and then you have the spinal
cord in the spinal column there's just
not enough space for the spinal cord and
so there's obstruction on the spinal
cord and that can definitely cause leg
pain okay
so that could come from either the
ligaments around the spinal column being
too thick it can come from arthritis or
spurring okay right next to the joints
or it can also come from just
inflammation that just won't allow the
space to open up so with this right here
i would highly recommend you work on
getting the curve back on your lower
back first okay i'll put the videos down
below
getting rid of refined carbs and sugar
taking
things like vitamin k2 to help maybe
possibly remove some calcium
and if you tried everything and
nothing's worked there's a really great
non-invasive surgery
that my mother did that was very
effective and trim that thickened um
ligament and take out these little
osteophytes and spurring
i mean the hole they go through is like
a very small hole and they're covered up
with a band-aid it's not a major
laminectomy where they're doing
all sorts of uh
invasive type work
because here's the problem when you do
surgery the scar tissue after the
surgery is sometimes worse than the
actual
before the surgery so
i'll write down that procedure down
below but there is a point where people
need surgery all right so for the next
video that you should watch it should be
this one right here for the tight psoas
i put it up right here check it out